so tell us about YouTube how do you find
yourself in this space in your career
it's weird I'm suddenly a suit which is
very alarming sometimes to be on the
other side of the table it's funny
because in the first couple of weeks
here you know I'm I'm the lead
programmer or the Lee created executive
force in effects even though I do direct
trailer hitch and I do direct badass
digest which is more instinctive a thing
for me to go out and make the shows and
edit the shows than it is for me to
preside an executive position even
though that's my role I've never been in
more meetings in my life you know that's
a lot there's a lot of you know here's
the funny thing here's the thing that I
think is very interesting every meeting
I ever went to or I pitched something
where there was a film idea or a
television idea you know I probably
spent the whole week at least prepping
for this meeting and you go in there and
it's you care so much and you're sitting
there with these people on the other
side of the desk when you're pitching
your thing and then you know the odds
are that nine times out of ten you know
no one says hey you got a deal I mean
then never I mean I think once in my
entire career once or twice my tiger did
I actually pitch something that actually
got like picked up and I was saying this
to my wife I wonder if I wish I could
calculate I wish I had had the nerve to
write down every meeting I've ever been
to as a filmmaker going in to try to get
something done because it's probably
millions of them and so the the
percentage is crazy you know you're
always there's so many things that go
nowhere all right so the point is now
I'm on the other side just for this year
and people are coming in to pitch their
stuff and now I'm suddenly one of these
jerk-offs on the other side of the table
you know listening and what I realize is
that all those times that I pitched
something that it didn't get picked up
and I took it personally where I was
like oh they don't like me or my ideas
not good enough or I suck or whatever
it's like the least it's the most
impersonal thing in the world because an
executive it's got so much crap so much
that's all I do is go to meetings all
day long there's so many things that
they're dealing with that what you
consider the most
part of the day which is you pitching
this thing it's like a blip to the
executive so unless what you're offering
is exactly this it's like every
production company or every studio has
like a couple of like puzzle pieces that
it's very specific sheet puzzle pieces
they're looking to fit and if what
you're pitching doesn't fit exactly this
and pick those buttons it's a no it's
gonna be a note every time and I always
was like oh this is so depressed and
it's not that at all it's just that I
suddenly am able to see that number one
second if don't really care about your
dreams and your hopes and how important
the ideas to you all I care about is
whether or not what you're selling fits
exactly whatever their little thing is
they're trying to do and maybe they
don't even know what that is and I found
myself in the first few weeks and I
still do it trying to tell to the people
who are pitching that I'm not one of
these guys like I'm you you know and
it's very hard to do in a meeting to say
well you know you might think I'm this
suit but I'm actually more you than I am
this thing that you think I am and I am
so deathly afraid of people perceiving
me as this you know part of the
establishment yeah yeah but it is a
crazy it is like two separate points
just two different universes operating
on the executive side and and to a
certain degree I understand why it's so
little gets done really because there's
a lot of weighing of is this worth doing
and is this gonna yield this result and
is this going to how this gonna impact
the brand and the company and all this
like hesitation because there's so much
money at stake whereas when you're a
creative person all you're interested in
doing is birthing this idea and that's
what's that's what feeds the creative
person which feeds the executive is that
their job is secure and that they don't
make a bonehead decision that gets them
fired and that whatever they put their
name on is successful in financial terms
whereas a creative person sure they want
to be rich and famous and all that
you know but for the most part it's
always about is is this idea good to be
created in a way that satisfies me as an
artist you know and at least that's
where that's how I think about it and so
it's like wearing these two different
hats it's like being Jekyll and Hyde or
something it's like this weird very
strange thing to do in Hobbit people
versus yeah it's it's but it's it it's
given me an insight into the it's sort
of like someone like it's like behind
the curtain you know like it I never
would have known how I mean I always
knew how it worked but I never really
stepped in the shoes of an executive nor
that I really want to I think part of it
has to do with me not wanting to be that
executive that I wanted to assassinate
you know and there's more of those than
there are the kindly you know empathetic
interest in executive so if I'm going to
be one of those I would prefer to be the
latter just so that you know I'm you
know well thought of during this process
you know but it's a very it's a very
unique position to be in
you